what do we do here we find water follow
me okay
what is your name well how do I look
like describe me you all right you have
a be a black hair a black mustache gold
rimmed glasses very three let's see
other name you're bald and black I don't
know what else to tell you Tim to
survive in the wild you have to be
stealthy like a cat there's a deer right
here very foggy this silent yeah
must be from all the we must be in
Jamaica everyone's smoking so much weed
so much weed where can we find this weed
oh my god you're fine oh my god
why don't we get back up okay we go here
No oh my god we did we're so [ __ ] man
you know what is this is like it's a
movie with Leonardo DiCaprio where we
jump into the water and it's like hold
my hand Tim I can hold your hand hold my
hand one movie oh why did he hold what
are you doing are you doing that right
click I can't give out whether makeup
for [ __ ] sake huh all right you ready
to jump
I'm ready three two promise you will
jump ya promise I'll jump okay three two
what you're not even looking at the lake
three you seriously jacking the jump
yeah a little look I'll jump
okay now we're never Tim okay three two
one I can't even jump
what is there's this magic force field
Oh
ethically back you go in there all right
let's go [ __ ] this way then I guess
oh my god we must be on that good stuff
we're like hallucinating the force field
is a forest wolf killing another deer
Jerrod
oh I like how its separated legs turn it
turn oh yeah I keep taking that damn
hey why don't you join me in the pond Oh
Vegas how romantic
it feels it was cold no no no no don't
worry just carry so hard right now I can
tell just just sniff my nipples oh my
god it's terrified your face is so scary
your nipples smell like cheddar cheese
doesn't it feel nice and warm just oh
i'm drinking water Oh what the [ __ ] that
I just did how did you do that
I pressed toy hell Oh if you hold a
whole D I'm not drinking all the e stand
here and hold thee oh look at a rock
good job Tim you did it I did it
we are surviving
why is there a giant [ __ ] hole here
why
all right look at camp fire really same
really holy [ __ ] you're right there's
hope
oh there's water too look there's a man
sleeping here
oh hey guys I got this oh yeah let's get
me just get this out
excuse me please all right grab your
[ __ ] I got this is my main [ __ ] doing
main [ __ ] named Carl oh there's a tent
there zip this up you know wait let me
check out a nice ass I'm gonna make sure
it's clean I don't want you to get
anywhere diseases
okay how's it look yeah I know it smells
it smells great I get in this tent all
right perfect
what I dono keep kicking okay I can't
get this way - Carl what I'm swimming my
[ __ ]
yeah use both hands - yes I use both
hands
why would I not use both hands doesn't
get this sexy piece of tail on my
shoulder I don't know what happened I
got so much money out of this game there
was a top seller for so long and this is
it this is as good as it gets
let's throw our main [ __ ] off the men
there'll be a proper funeral okay we're
gonna make it the mountain it's really
far away
probably night it's probably just a
backdrop all right well I guess will
they farm the mountains like and
favorite and subscribe to find out in
the next episode dan tan tan
will they come will they have any sexual
transmitted diseases find out in the
next episode this is a great game I'm
glad we bought this game array for games
ray